.
WE'RE GOING TAKE YOU THERE.
LET'S GO "OUTFRONT."
GOOD EVENING.
I'M ERIN BURNETT.
"OUTFRONT" TONIGHT, THE BREAKING
NEWS.
TRUMP SUFFERING TWO MAJOR LEGAL
BLOWS.
THE FIRST, GOODBYE SPECIAL
MASTER.
A FEDERAL APPEALS COURT STOPPING
THE SPECIAL MASTER'S REVIEW OF
SENSITIVE DOCUMENTS SEIZED AT
TRUMP'S HOME, MAR-A-LAGO.
OF COURSE YOU'LL REMEMBER, IT
WAS A FEW MONTHS AGO IN
SEPTEMBER WHEN JUDGE AILEEN
CANNON, WHO SEE HER ON YOUR
SCREEN NOW, WHO WAS APPOINTED BY
TRUMP SIDED WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND APPOINTED A
SPECIAL MASTER, WHICH OF COURSE
ADDED TIME.
EVERYTHING HAD TO BE REVIEWED,
STRETCHING THIS WHOLE PROCESS
OUT.
THE DOJ APPEALED SAYING THAT
THAT REVIEW AND ALL THIS TIME
WOULD CAUSE IRREPARABLE HARM TO
THEIR INVESTIGATION.
AND THE 11th CIRCUIT COURT
TONIGHT AGREEING, SLAMMING
CANNON'S DECISION.
LET ME JUST READ A PART OF THIS
HERE IN THE RULING.
THEY SAY "THE LAW IS CLEAR.
WE CANNOT WRITE A RULE THAT
ALLOWS ANY SUBJECT OF A SEARCH
WARRANT TO BLOCK GOVERNMENT
INVESTIGATIONS AFTER THE
EXECUTION OF THE WARRANT, NOR
CAN WE WRITE A RULE THAT ALLOWS
ONLY FORMER PRESIDENTS TO DO
SO."
NOW I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR HERE
GOING THROUGH THIS THAT THE
JUDGES WHO WROTE THIS RULING IS
MADE UP OF JUDGES NOMINATED BY
THE FORMER PRESIDENTS GEORGE W.
BUSH AND DONALD TRUMP.
SO THAT'S THE FIRST BLOW, RIGHT,
RELATED TO MAR-A-LAGO.
IT IS SIGNIFICANT.
THE OTHER, THOUGH, MATTERS A LOT
TONIGHT TOO.
IT IS REGARDING ANOTHER FEDERAL
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION, THIS ONE
INTO TRUMP'S EFFORTS TO OVERTURN
THE 2020 ELECTION.
TONIGHT A FEDERAL JUDGE ORDERING
TWO ATTORNEYS TO TESTIFY, PAT
CIPOLLONE, TRUMP'S FORMER WHITE
HOUSE COUNCIL, AND HIS DEPUTY
PATRICK PHILBIN TO COME BEFORE
THE GRAND JURY.
REJECTS CLAIMSES OF EXECUTIVE
AND ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
THAT WAS REJECTED.
NOW BOTH LAWYERS ARE CRUCIAL IN
THE JANUARY 6th CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
THERE IS A LOT TO GET TO
TONIGHT.
I WANT TO BEGIN WITH EVAN PEREZ
IN WASHINGTON.
SO EVAN, LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS
MAR-A-LAGO RULING, THE SPECIAL
MASTER THAT WAS SO CRUCIAL TO
ALL OF THIS IN SEPTEMBER, AND
NOW A STUNNING RULING, RIGHT,
SIGNIFICANT RULING ABOUT THE
SPECIAL MASTER.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
>> WELL, IT MEANS THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, ERIN, THAT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INVESTIGATION CAN CONTINUE
UNFETTERED, BECAUSE THIS -- THE
EARLIER RULING FROM THE LOWER
COURT JUDGE AILEEN CANNON, THAT
HAD ESSENTIALLY ACTED TO IMPEDE
WHAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WAS
TRYING TO DO, WHICH WAS REVIEW
THESE DOCUMENTS, PURSUE THIS
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION INTO THE
ALLEGED MISHANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
AND WHAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT
WAS ASKING WAS SPECIAL
TREATMENT.
THAT'S PLAIN AND SIMPLE WHAT HE
WAS ASKING FOR.
AND THE 11th CIRCUIT, TWO JUDGES
WHO WERE APPOINTED BY THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, AND A THIRD ONE,
ANOTHER REPUBLICAN APPOINTEE,
I'LL READ YOU ANOTHER PART OF
THE RULING.
IT SAYS THE RESTRAINT GUARDS
AGAINST NEEDLESS JUDICIAL
INTRUSION INTO THE COURSE OF
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS, THIS
FEAR OF POWER COMMITTED TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THESE JUDGES WERE
PARTICULARLY FOCUSED ON DURING
THE ORAL ARGUMENTS JUST A FEW
DAYS AGO.
THEY WERE PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IDEA THAT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT THE FORMER PRESIDENT WAS
ASKING FOR WAS ESSENTIALLY
SOMETHING THAT ANYONE THEN COULD
ASK FOR, WHICH IS TO -- FOR
JUDGES TO INTERVENE IN AN
ONGOING CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
AND TO TRY TO STOP WHAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WAS DOING.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY ALSO WHAT THE
JUDGE HERE IN WASHINGTON DID AND
THE OTHER INVESTIGATION.
SHE BASICALLY HAS SAID THE
FORMER PRESIDENT CAN'T CLAIM
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE AND
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE OVER
SOME OF THESE DISCUSSIONS THAT
HAD TO DO WITH THIS CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION OF WHAT HAPPENED
ON JANUARY 6th.
NOW IN BOTH CASES, ERIN, WE
EXPECT THAT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, HE HAS THE OPTION TO
APPEAL IN THE 11th CIRCUIT.
HE CAN PROBABLY GO TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
WE'LL SEE WHETHER HE DOES THAT
IN THE CASE OF THE RULING
AGAINST HIM IN HIS -- THE FORMER
LAWYERS OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE CAN ALSO APPEAL TO THE
APPEALS COURT HERE IN
WASHINGTON.
BUT HE HAS BEEN LOSING AND
LOSING BIG IN ALL OF THESE
CASES.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WELL, EVAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO LET'S GO TO RYAN GOODMAN,
JUST SECURITY CO-EDITOR IN
CHIEF.
AND JOHN DEAN, FORMER NIXON
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL.
YOU'VE READ THROUGH THE 21 PAGES
HERE.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THE
RULING ABOUT THE SPECIAL MASTER
FIRST?
>> IT IS A STUNNING REBUKE OF
THE JUDGE CANNON OPINIONS, AND
IT'S A STUNNING REBUKE OF
TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAMS ARGUMENTS ON
WHICH HE BASED THOSE OPINIONS.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO THINK OF
EXAMPLES LIKE THIS IN A
PROFESSIONAL CAREER OF ANY
DISTRICT COURT JUDGE TO BE SO
STRONGLY REPUDIATED BY THE COURT
OF APPEALS.
AND THEY'VE DONE IT IN SUCH A
SOLID MANNER TERMS OF SAYING
THAT NONE OF THE FACTORS THAT
TRUMP NEEDED TO MEET WAS HE ABLE
TO MEET, THAT I THINK IT'S VERY,
VERY, VERY UNLIKELY THAT THE
SUPREME COURT WILL DO ANYTHING
BUT JUST LET THIS OPINION STAND.
AND WE SHOULD ALSO REMEMBER THAT
ONE OF THE JUDGES IN THIS
OPINION IS THE CHIEF JUDGE OF
THE 11th CIRCUIT.
SO IT'S REALLY A REMARKABLE
OPINION, AND IT DOES STAND FOR
THE RULE OF LAW BECAUSE THEY
JUST DID A VERY METICULOUS JOB
APPLYING THE LAW TO THE FACTS.
>> METICULOUS AND FIRM THERE WAS
NO MINCING OF WORDS, RIGHT?
IT WAS VERY CLEAR THAT THEY
FOUND THIS ABSURD, JOHN.
LET ME READ AGAIN SOME OF THE
RULING THAT I SHARED AT THE TOP
OF THE SHOW.
"WE CANNOT WRITE A RULE THAT
ALLOWS ANY SUBJECT OF A SEARCH
WARRANT TO BLOCK GOVERNMENT
INVESTIGATIONS AFTER THE
EXECUTION OF THE WARRANT, NOR
CAN WE WRITE A RULE THAT ALLOWS
ONLY FORMER PRESIDENTS TO DO
SO."
USING THE WORD "REBUKE," RIGHT,
AS RYAN DID, IT SEEMS TO BE
COMPLETELY ACCURATE.
HOW BIG A BLOW IS THIS TO TRUMP,
JOHN?
>> WELL, IT'S A DIRECT BLOW.
AS EVAN SAID EARLIER, THIS WAS
AN EFFORT BY TRUMP TO REACH OUT
AND GET SOME SPECIAL TREATMENT.
THESE ARE JUDGES HE APPOINTED.
HE'S GOT A SUPREME COURT THAT HE
HAS APPOINTED THREE MEMBERS OF.
AND HE WANTS SPECIAL TREATMENT,
AND HE IS NOT GETTING IT.
HE IS BEING TREATED LIKE EVERY
OTHER CITIZEN BEFORE THE COURT,
AND THE COURT MADE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE DOING IS
TREATING HIM LIKE EVERYBODY
ELSE.
AND NOT GOING TO CHANGE THE
PROCESS JUST FOR HIM.
>> AND RYAN, YOUR SOURCES
TELLING TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM
HASN'T DECIDED TO APPEAL THIS.
YOU MADE IT CLEAR THAT COULDN'T
IMPACT IT AT ALL.
IT COULD DRAG IT OUT MORE.
BUT JUST TO BE CLEAR, RIGHT, THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL NOW OVERSEES
BOTH OF THE INVESTIGATIONS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE, THE
MAR-A-LAGO WHERE WE JUST GOT A
RULING OBVIOUSLY AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE JANUARY
6th INVESTIGATION.
SO WHEN IT COMES TO THE
MAR-A-LAGO INVESTIGATION, IF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL INDEED IS GONE,
WHAT DOES THIS DO TO THE
TIMELINE HERE OF A DECISION ON
AN INDICTMENT OR ANYTHING ELSE
FROM THE SPECIAL COUNSEL, RYAN?
>> SO I THINK THAT IT DOES MEAN
THAT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL WILL BE
ABLE TO MORE QUICKLY REACH THE
DECISION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT TO
INDICT DONALD TRUMP.
HE NOW KNOWS THAT HE HAS ALL OF
THE MATERIAL FROM THE FBI SEARCH
THAT HE CAN NOW BRING TO A TRIAL
AND BRING TO A JURY.
THAT WAS ALWAYS A BIG QUESTION
THAT WAS OVERHANGING HIM.
YOU NEVER KNEW WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN
WITH THOSE DOCUMENTS.
AND NOW THAT'S FIRMLY IN HIS
POSSESSION, AND HE KNOWS THAT HE
CAN PRESENT IT AS EVIDENCE.
THAT'S HUGE.
AND ALL ARROWS ARE POINTING
TOWARDS THIS BEING A CASE THAT
COULD BE PROSECUTED.
AND THEN THE OTHER PART IS JUST
NOW THAT THEY HAVE THESE
MATERIALS AND THEY CAN USE THEM,
IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER REMAINING
QUESTIONS WITH WITNESSES, THEY
ARE ABLE TO ASK THE WITNESSES
ABOUT THESE SPECIFIC DOCUMENTS.
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO DO THAT
BECAUSE OF THE DISTRICT COURT
JUDGE'S KIND OF RADICAL
INJUNCTION IN THE PAST.
I THINK IT REALLY PUTS THEM ON A
STRONG FOOTING, PUTS THINGS
MOVING RAPIDLY AHEAD AT A GOOD
CLIP.
>> THE WORD RAPIDLY AHEAD IS AN
IMPORTANT ONE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MAR-A-LAGO,
OBVIOUSLY THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
HAS A DECISION TO GOOD AHEAD,
RAPIDLY MAKE A DECISION ON
INDICTING THERE, OR WHETHER TO
WAIT UNTIL THE JANUARY 6th
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
INVESTIGATION IS ALSO WRAPPED UP
AND SOMEHOW PUT THEM TOGETHER.
SO JOHN, AT THAT POINT, THE
OTHER BLOW TO TRUMP THAT I
MENTIONED, RIGHT, THE FEDERAL
JUDGE ORDERING PAT CIPOLLONE,
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE COUNCIL
AND HIS DEPUTY PATRICK PHILBIN
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL GRAND JURY
IN THAT CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION,
PRIVILEGE, EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
WAS OBVIOUSLY REJECTED.
WHAT DOES THIS TELL YOU?
>> WELL, TRUMP HAS BEEN UP AND
DOWN THIS ROAD BEFORE.
HE'S TRIED TO HAVE HIS LAWYERS
INVOKE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
HE'S PRESSED THEM TO DO.
SO THEY'RE NOT REALLY REQUIRED
TO DO SO.
BUT THEY DID SO OUT OF HONORING
THEIR CLIENT'S COMMITMENT.
BUT IT DIDN'T WORK NOW.
AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED AS THE
GRAND JURY APPEALED THEIR
REFUSAL.
THEY'RE NOW GOING TO HAVE TO
OPEN UP AND TELL EVERYTHING THEY
KNOW.
TRUMP HAS NO EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
IF HE TRIES TO APPEAL THIS, IT'S
NOT GOING TO GO ANYWHERE.
HE HAS ALREADY DONE THIS SEVERAL
TIMES IN D.C.
AND THOSE COURTS ARE EXHAUSTED
WITH HIS EFFORTS TO BLOCK
TESTIMONY.
TO BE CLEAR, THESE TWO ATTORNEYS
HAVE ALREADY TESTIFIED.
SO WHAT DOES IT SAY TO YOU THAT
THEY'RE BEING CALLED BACK?
>> I DO THINK IT MEANS THAT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS PUTTING
TOGETHER KIND OF FINAL PIECES.
THESE ARE KEY WITNESSES THAT CAN
TELL THE SPECIAL COUNSEL AND THE
GRAND JURY OF DIRECT
COMMUNICATIONS WITH TRUMP.
AND WE KNOW THAT THEY HAVE SAID
THAT VARIOUS PARTS OF TRUMP'S
PLAN TO OVERTURN THE JANUARY 6th
ELECTION WERE ILLEGAL, THE FALSE
SLATE OF ELECTORS WAS ILLEGAL.
TRYING TO GET PENCE TO NOT
CERTIFY WAS ILLEGAL.
BUT WE HAVEN'T HEARD THEM SAY
WHAT THEY TOLD PRESIDENT TRUMP
AT THE TIME AND WHAT TRUMP'S
REACTION WAS